there's been an enormous amount of
changing forces on warfare in the 21st
century
and they range from new actors in war
like private contractors the black
waters of the world to the growth of
warlord and child soldier groups to
technologic shifts the introduction of
robotics to cyber and one of the
interesting things that ties these
together is how not only the who of war
is being expanded but also the where and
the win so one of the things that links
for example drones and robotics with
cyber weapons is that you're seeing a
shift in both the geographic location of
the human role humans are still involved
we're not in the world of the Terminator
humans are still involved but there's
been a geographic shift where the
operation can be happening in Pakistan
but the person flying the plane might be
back in Nevada 7,000 miles away or on
the cyber side where the software might
be hitting Iranian nuclear research
center fuchsias like what Stuxnet did
but the people who designed it and
decided to send it are again thousands
of miles away and in that case it was a
combined u.s. Israeli operation one of
the next steps in this both with the
physical side of robotics and the
software side of soft
cyber is a shift in that human role not
just geographically but chronologically
where the humans are still making
decisions but they're sending the weapon
out in the world to then make its own
decisions as it plays out there in
robotics we think about this as autonomy
with Stuxnet it was a weapon it was a
weapon like anything else in history you
know a stone a drone it caused physical
damage but it was sent out in the world
on a mission in a way no previous weapon
is done go out find this one target
and cause harm to that target and
nothing else and so it plays out over a
matter of you know Stuxnet plays out
over a series of time it also is
interesting because it's the first
weapon that can be both here they're
everywhere and nowhere
unlike a stone unlike a drone it's not a
thing
and so that software is hitting the
target those Iranian nuclear research
facilities but it also pops up in 25,000
other computers around the world that's
actually how we discover it how we know
about it the final thing that makes this
interesting is it introduces a difficult
ethical wrinkle on one hand we can say
this may have been the the first ethical
weapons ever developed again whether
we're talking about the robots or
Stuxnet they can be programmed to do
things that we would describe as
potentially ethical so Stuxnet could
only cause harm to its intended target
yet popped up in twenty five thousand
computers around the world but it could
only harm the ones with this particular
set up this particular geographic
location of doing nuclear research in
fact even if you had nuclear centrifuges
in your basement it still wouldn't harm
them it could only hit those Iranian
ones wow that's great
but as the person who discovered it so
to speak put it it's like opening
Pandora's box and not everyone is going
to program it that way
with ethics in mind
you